good as we get ready to start this round
two we jump up upstairs to the playing
hall where the players are just now
taking their seats
absolutely an
important route here good to start off
and uh for those of you who are aware we
do have some bad news as you look
at the starting position that is not the
starting position in fact that is the
starting position
for this faznikov
sicilian featured in the open sicilian
the move e7e5
afghanistan
championed this move therefore it bears
his name with his
friend timochenko
unfortunately afghani has passed
and the players are paying their
respects by putting this position on the
board and a moment of silence
a grand man a grand old man of chess
afghani but
71 years young i don't like that he had
complicated factors health factors and
he passed due to the covet that is very
unfortunate a legend of chess such an
inspiration for many generations i know
that i grew up
analyzing fashion clubs games his
contributions to theory and how he just
shaped so many different openings to his
own will and made them work somehow of
course yes he did also a big
supporter helper for anatoly karpov he
he described it as pouring water into
the vessel
his his work with uh talia and well i i
knew him uh
from many decades ago
i actually hustled him in blitz in a
tournament in hastings it was a great
deal of fun
and tigran petrossian was kibbutzing our
games cash
cash
on that one that was
wow but you know when a great star like
shreshlikov arrives on the scene and
puts this his stamp on opening theory
forever you just have to give respect to
those kind of legends they don't become
the world champions
those names that we
will ring throughout history forever but
with their name on
the openings they say listen i did this
and players have been following this
theory including the world champions for
decades
and have been for decades to come